avete presente che ogni tanto ci sono
dei giochi brutti ma che merita comunque
di essere visti perché nella loro
bruttezza sono fantastici
oggi ve ne propongo due e poi vi
domandate il perché io reputo brutto un
gioco sono neanche partito è già così
bella a tutti ragazzi permette questo
video sono famiglie oggi siamo su melone
in the dark james tarda venete eccome
l'om il call center sempre a mio zio
toni non lo voglio sapere
ma quanto è poligonale questo gioco user
anche is ok ha veramente io sono che
slang di gamba che a quest'uomo presso
and space praticamente nel nostro se
conoscete gioco alone in the dark che
quel giorno al famosissimo che andava un
tempo bene hanno fatto melone in the
dark 15 le angurie sul muro bellissimo
melone di the dark e signori questo
gioco non voglio uscire o un melone in
cucina si ma me lo stai dicendo che un
quale camminata zio di questo si muove e
straziata bellissimo posso entrare qua
dentro
come si entra bene quanto è raro che
questo gioco quanto spetta suspense che
tavolo sexy si è chiusa la porta c'è un
melone sulla sulla c'è un melone tutto
circolare poco poligonale sul tavolo
ok un meraviglioso melone
è un melone cattivo che cosa sta
succedendo lo zio è un ma cos'è ma cos'è
di meloni sono persone brutte gold space
adesso da gioco della vita non mi sento
molto bene
ma che cos'è maki maki
perfetto devil may cry può accompagnare
o l'anguria bene
sono scene anche una sopra la credenza
non mi ricordo l'ultima volta che ho
giocato a una roba così bella le movenze
sono dei bolli bolli bolli e la vuota
cura you i'm the stream watch per fare
vuota
no ragazzi prego vi prego ditemi che è
finito qua non voglio proseguire
va bene va bene va bene va bene sono
contento così melor in the dark di
quanta gente che l'ha fatto berni lo
tiles si vedeva era fatto bene qui dice
team che ha lavorato anni tra o funding
lorenzo pilia con quale dignità t t
appropri del mio nome zio firmiamo una
petizione perché questo videogioco possa
arrivare su playstation 4 passiamo al
prossimo videogioco ragazzi sono il
secondo ascensore sono nuovamente qui su
tom waits damon che vuol dire vai con la
tua ex apprese di quito continua ragazzi
questo gioco horror nel caso si fosse
capito dal menu poi c'è questa
canzoncina bella neomelodica che
ti manda un pò in chilling ci siano
ragazzi siamo ovviamente ci siamo
svegliati in un posto che non sappiamo
che cos'è
ok non pensavo si rompessero davvero ho
rotto le scatole sono simpatico
iscrivetevi al mio canale vuole non
volevo rompere tutto volevo
semplicemente salve
c'è un tizio che dentro c'è il sole c'è
un fungo lì siamo ad amsterdam c'è uno
zaino
c'è una molotov e del succo di frutta e
queste due cose insieme funzionano molto
bene
mangiamo i funghi
ciao zio è è unitario faccio i soldi con
youtube pam
matera una mazzetta da sotto i denti
chetoni f può accompagnare sono comunque
terminati aia la pre bello sto gioco mi
piace proprio
va bè ragazzi non so se effettivamente
posso farlo fuori con il tizio però si
sta roba
ancora insomma perché trovi i succhi di
frutta cosa me ne faccio
ho trovato uno zaino segreto sherlock
holmes spostati una bottiglia di birra
ma perché non trovano baudi e ai ragazzi
allora devo trovare delle con una roccia
come già qualcosa posso cambiare arma
come le cavie le armi
la vedo adesso non cambia niente cos'è
sesta porta salve questa è la moglie di
hulk non so che brutta gonna get up e di
come faccia battere una chiesa due falsi
ma cosa sono entrato nella stanza di un
po ma sì vabbè rega ma non ho manco le
armi ma non riesco neanche a giocare a
nascondino ma figurati abate hulk noti
da attenzioni il che non è abbastanza
grosso pulisci to torna in cucina brava
torre forse non darne cucina non
esattamente il modo migliore per fare
amicizia però che porta bella ma ciao
questa guerra entrata di kiko tra
l'altro mi mise non è vero
riesco a farmi nemiche pure le porte ma
sei serio dai ragazzi in questa l'ultima
porta che non ha aperto tra l'altro se
riesco a trovare un'arma
sono contento salve è perfetto
adesso riparati signori michael jackson
avevi st pagnottella ci arrivano a
mazzetta tacche svieni la mazza e data
sotto ecco che ti piace sto berretto
ragazzi con chi non per dire a questo
gioco costa 15 euro e alla zia di vita
fin ha calmato ok 14 euro e 99 dei
ragazzi questi erano i due giochi brutti
di oggi per questo io faccio i giovani
per portare a voi contenuti di qualità
ragazzi ragazzi ho bisogno del vostro
supporto fatemi vedere stielike vogliamo
arrivare a 40mila like per un prossimo
episodio sui giochi i quali l'umanità
non ha bisogno ma noi sì questi ragazzi
sparaventi se mi sento così commentate
mi piace anche vari social che come
iniziare
stasera scritti siete lì ci rimettiamo
al prossimo video ed ai ragazzi
[Musica]